Good morning, Hank, it’s Tuesday.
I’m doing a photoshoot in which they want
me to pretend to vlog so I’m going to actually
vlog.
Here are all the people taking my picture.
Woke up in Los Angeles at 6:15 in the morning
on Saturday, brushed my teeth, got my picture
taken while taking moving pictures of myself,
and then got on a hotel elevator clearly not
designed for people who fear heights.
I don’t like this at all.
Met up with Eleanor & Park author Rainbow
Rowell and then went to USC for the L.A. Times
book festival where my long time editor Julie
Strauss-Gabel was talking to Maya Van Wagenen,
a 15-year-old who has written a fascinating
and wonderful anthropological experiment/memoir
called Popular.
And then I got to ride in a golf cart - you
can just see my glee - before heading backstage
to prepare for my event.
I was very nervous backstage, but man, the
lighting was fantastic.
Hank, before I go on stage for book stuff
now, I always remind myself of my readings,
and there were many of them, that were attended
by between 0 and 3 people, and I give thanks
for Brotherhood 2.0 and Nerdfighteria and
for you, Hank, and then I take a deep breath
and, well… (crowd cheering)
So I talked to all these nice people for a
while, and then went over to sign books for
several hours where I met lots of people wearing
various "okay, okay" shirts, and TFIOS iPhone
cases, and TFIOS nails, and a dog named Alaska,
and this couple who met through Nerdfighteria
and now are married.
Then I met up with my friend Veronica Roth,
and shortly thereafter, fell asleep in the
cab on the way back to the hotel.
I was trying to film myself fake falling asleep,
but then I actually fell asleep, so it goes…
Woke up the next morning at 5:15 to watch
Liverpool - Manchester City, which was wonderful,
and then terrifying, and then wonderful again.
Yes!
We did it, Hank.
We being, of course, the people on the pitch,
the people in the stadium, and me in Los Angeles
wearing my Liverpool jacket.
And then I got to see my friend T Cooper who
wrote Changers, and then I headed to different
hotel to meet…
Oh, look, it’s Ansel Elgort, who plays Gus
in The Fault in Our Stars, and whose worldview
involves a great deal of shirtlessness, and
frankly, who among us can blame him?
Sarah was there too and we drank champagne
by the pool which was awesome, and then we
got all fancy for the MTV Movie Awards, met
up with Nat Wolff, and soon found ourselves
on an actual red carpet.
Hank, I really love Nerdfighteria and the
chance to talk about stuff I care about with
people I care about, but I don’t particularly
wanna be, like, a real celebrity, which is
why we've always turned down TV stuff, but
I’m really proud of the TFIOS movie and
I want to support it, and plus I like hanging
out with Nat, so there we were on the very
same red carpet as, like, Jonah Hill and Grumpy
Cat.
Nat and I tried to answer questions even though
the screaming and the cameras resulted in
both of us, to use internet parlance, losing
our ability to even.
It was really, really overwhelming, Hank,
and interviewers kept asking me how I was
handling the attention that accompanies a
book becoming a movie and if our community
would change because of it, and I wanted to
answer every question by saying “I AM FREAKING
OUT RIGHT NOW!”
And I found myself thinking of Grumpy Cat,
who, in spite of it all, remained, you know,
cat-like, and grumpy, and I thought: “You
know what?
Grumpy Cat has this thing figured out!”
So Nerdfighteria, this is gonna be weird and
hopefully awesome, but let’s just focus
on continuing to do the stuff that we're good
at, okay?
And on that subject:
Hi, Hank.
Me from the future here.
In a stunning turn of events, I find myself
in an airport.
Anyway, we are relaunching the Nerdfighter
Book Club, and our new book is going to be
Behind the Beautiful Forevers, by Katherine
Boo, a fascinating and nuanced look at poverty
in one Indian community, so check it out;
link's in the doobly-doo.